omar faruk el type es la primera víctima
mortal de esta nueva ola de protestas
que ha empezado desde hace 4 días
aquí en trípoli la ciudad más pobre del
líbano y la gente ha salido a protestar
precisamente para mejorar sus
condiciones de vida y además debido a
las estrictas normas de confinamiento
han empeorado ya que no pueden trabajar
porque la gente tiene que estar
confinada en sus casas
omar al igual que a muchos vecinos de
aquí del barrio de bab al tabani no
tenía trabajo y con 30 años tampoco
podía casarse porque no tenía recursos
económicos miles de vecinos de babette
habana y de otras partes de trípoli han
venido a rendir homenaje a esta primera
víctima después de que anoche hubieran
fuertes manifestaciones al igual que el
resto de los días pero ayer las fuerzas
de seguridad utilizaron fuego real
contra los manifestantes y omar fue una
de las víctimas de las doscientas
personas que resultaron heridas pero que
no pudo conseguirlo y esta mañana murió
por culpa de las heridas